one of my favorite pastimes both in
childhood and then as a teenager and
well into my 20s was fishing and
typically I would use a spinning or bait
casting rod and reel and I really got
started into that by going fishing with
my dad when I was pretty young probably
four or five years old we got started
and I'm going to tell you a story about
a fish that we caught that was almost a
state record white bass in just a few
but I want to give you a little bit of
background about my dad and his dad and
fishing and all of that sort of stuff
so it's clear that fishing was something
important not just for my dad and and me
as a kid but it was something that was
passed on from his own father taking him
fishing and my grandpa I never knew him
this way but you know previous to his
retirement he was a pretty busy guy and
he'd worked his way up through the
corporate ladder he eventually became
like a major consultant for the Glidden
Corporation and did all sorts of stuff
and he you know so he made time to spend
time with my dad who was actually his
second son he'd have a previous son in a
earlier marriage where he divorced and
actually didn't have too much to do with
his son until much much later on but my
dad was the you know the only child with
my grandmother and my my grandpa kind of
spoiled him in part because he could
and part of that was uh taking him
fishing and they did a lot of cool
fishing trips together you know we have
photographs of them up in Canada where
you had to fly in and get a guide and
they'd go musky and pike fishing and
that was something that my my own dad
wanted for me and to a lesser extent I
think my my sister who was not quite as
interested in fishing and I don't think
we she she and him had that kind of bond
and so you know early on my dad taught
me how to fish and he would take me
fishing
um so some of my earliest memories are
of going out on Lake nagawica waking up
really early in the morning when it was
still dark and we would you know drive
to the bait shop with the two rods that
we had which are very very nice bait
casting rods beautifully enameled and
wonderful reels and then you know these
big tackle boxes and and back then we
didn't have the boat so my dad would
rent a row boat and then we would you
know row out into the lake when I say we
he did the rowing obviously and we'd
have like some sandwiches along and
stuff like that and then we'd we'd fish
and you know we spent a lot of time kind
of in silence my dad gave me that line
you know don't want to talk because that
old official here and that'll spook them
I think he probably enjoyed the you know
the noises of the lake so to speak but
just hanging out together and catching
things you know little catfish panfish
of different sorts and all of that and
then you know later on down the line uh
you know my dad had a good job as a tax
attorney and one of the things that he
he wanted for us as a family was to have
a boat and so by the time that I was in
grade school and I don't remember
exactly what year we got the boat maybe
third grade you know
um he bought this this tri-haul 18
footer and we christened it the Green
Arrow and we were out on mostly Lake
nagawica and then we'd take River trips
and I've talked about this in some other
uh of my stories as well and uh we
actually like did a river trip one time
down the Mississippi with uh two other
boats and families and that was a lot of
fun for for about a week
um but in any case we would spend a lot
of time out on Lake nagawica as a family
and we would you know
um get you know inner tubes and air
mattresses and swim and get pulled
behind and you know have have lunch and
sometimes even dinner out there and you
know putter around the lake and we would
fish we would often go by the island and
fish for perch or we would go to other
places but here's where we get to the
story about this uh white bass there's a
part of Lake nagawica that's called the
kettle and it's you know it's its own
little bubble of of the lake and
um there's kind of a narrow channel that
attaches it to the lake
and it's full of marsh and and you know
kind of Blends off into the marshlands
around that area and that's a great
place to fish or at least it was back
then and so quite often my dad and I
would you know on a Saturday morning or
you know sometimes like after school
when he wasn't working too late he'd
come home and he'd be like pack up the
boat we're gonna go fishing for a while
and so then you know we drive out there
and we put the boat in you know we had
he had a station wagon and a trailer and
he'd he'd have to go park it and I'd be
holding the boat you know waiting for
him sometimes in the mornings he'd
actually like drive off to the nearby
and when I say nearby like a couple
miles away McDonald's and get us some
Egg McMuffins and hash browns and come
back and we'd go out and fish so we did
this a lot him and me and we would fish
with all sorts of things minnows worms
helgromites which are dragonfly larva
whack worms you know and and we would
catch all sorts of interesting stuff
so anyway
it was you know in the middle of the
Fall I remember that and it was kind of
a gray drizzly day and it was you know I
was a day that I you know came home from
school and I think maybe my dad had come
home early and he was like let's go out
to the lake let's go fishing and I was
like ah that sounds great because I I
love fishing you know
so anyway
um we pack up we get down there we go
out to the kettle and you know it's
raining a little bit it's kind of gray
it's kind of cold and
um
we're catching you know things here and
there some bluegill
uh you know every once in a while you
might hook into something a little bit
bigger and then interestingly enough my
now I didn't actually hook this fish my
dad did so he I've got one rod he's got
another one they were red and green I
remember that beautifully enameled
um you know almost like
high-end bait casting rods and reels and
so anyway we're sitting there and he
gets a bite and you know of course you
gotta you gotta set the hook right so he
does that and you see the rod bending
down now these were some fairly heavy
rods these you know later on I got
myself a spinning setup with a a light
and I also had an ultra light Rod so
that you know even a bluegill would pull
it down quite a bit these were a little
bit stiffer you could use these for bass
fishing or even for pike fishing or
walleye fishing and so I see it going
down and he's like here take this I'll
take your your Rod you play the fish I
want to see how you do this
so I start doing it and uh at first I
was actually I you know I'd read about
Big Fish and stuff like that I was like
well I need to take the the line right
so and I I I'm going to like hit the
thing that will release the line he's
like no don't do that just let it pull
with the drag now fight the fish you
know and so it's about a good you know
three four minutes before we actually
can see the fish coming over and it's
not huge by today's standards but you
know when you're uh fourth grader a
nine-year-old it looks pretty damn big
so I see this fish and its mouth is like
this big and it's wide open and I get it
close and finally he's got you know the
net and he swings it under and pulls it
in and it's a white bass beautiful
striped right and it's uh pretty big you
know and and he's looking at it he's
like that's a damn big white bass and I
was like how how big is it he's like
well
you know we better go find out because
this this fish here this might be
something kind of special
so we get it in and we've you know got
the the the I forget what we call those
a Stringer the Stringer through its uh
its gills and we're keeping it in in
water
and my dad you know we pull the anchor
up and put the rods and reels down and
uh we start heading across the lake
because we got to go out of the kettle
and all the way across the lake to where
we used to rent the row boats and stuff
like that because there are docks there
and the docks are right across from
these bars and these bars are Fisherman
bars right so people would uh you know
have some beers and then go fishing or
they'd come back and have some beers and
hang out and my dad says um
well I'm going to go in you stay here at
the boat and I'm gonna go in with the
fish and we'll get some uh we'll get
some measurements we'll get it weighed
get it measured too how long it is
so he comes back after about 10 minutes
and he says well I got some good news
and I got some bad news
um and he says the good news is this is
a really big white bass you know
congratulations on catching it I'm so
proud of you uh for for doing that and
uh so much fun to do together
unfortunately it's not a record I
thought it might be actually but it's
actually one
ounce short of the state record
state record for white bass I don't know
what it was at the time but whatever it
was we were really really close to it
and he said everybody at the bar was you
know looking at it and they wanted to
check it out and there was a huge sigh
of disappointment when it didn't beat
the record you know and people had these
charts that would say what the record
were you know
um and you know they had a scale and all
that my dad I remember this to this day
he was like you know what I should have
done I should have dropped a couple
sinkers down its gullet before we took
it in to weigh it but that wouldn't have
been the right thing to do you know and
he was kind of like wavering back and
forth about that and so he said well you
know it's still a really big fish we're
going to take it home and figure out
what to do with it and and that'll be uh
pretty cool and I was like are we gonna
are we gonna eat it tonight and he's
like I don't know if this is an eaten
fish or not so
um long story short you know we take a
picture of it we actually had a pick
picture that we took I remember this in
front of our refrigerator
and then within about a week my dad must
have like you know had it developed and
then sent in the story there was
actually a story with that picture a
little blurb about me and my dad
catching this nearly state record white
bass in lake nagawica in the local paper
the Waukesha Freeman and you know it was
kind of funny because I I was like not
quite a celebrity but it certainly put
me on notice at my little Elementary
School everyone's like oh I saw the
story about you and the fish and all
that I've subsequently gone back and
tried to find it and it's not there
online maybe it's available in
microfiche somewhere and I probably
should track it down because it was kind
of a cool thing to to happen but there's
me in front of their refrigerator
holding up this this big white bass and
I thought that was the end of the story
but it actually wasn't
because unbeknownst to me
um
around Christmas time
there is a big package for me under the
tree like you know I would say like
18 inches by 18 inches by 18 inches like
a big Cube wrapped up and I was like
what could that be you know some
presents you could figure out right away
so anyway
uh we're all opening our Christmas
presents and I open this up and I look
down and there's all this tissue paper
and I'm like what what the hell is this
right so I start pulling all of it out
and there it is there's my fish
mounted by a taxidermist on a block of
wood and I think it might even said
something on the plaque but I don't
remember I've long since lost that
unfortunately I carried it with me from
place to place and I I would hang it
because that was like my one big fish
trophy you know it wasn't a huge fish
but it was it was pretty sizable like
this big and the taxidermist had done a
pretty good job on it and so you know
that was kind of a cool thing a Memento
because you know unfortunately my dad
was not going to live that much longer
after that I'll tell you about that in
in just a bit there is one other part of
the story that I do have to tell you and
that is that you know the they estimated
that the fish was probably like 18 to 20
years old so it had been there a very
long time and it had the opportunity to
grow quite a bit and they did save the
meat and so we had the meat and it was
terrible it tasted what uh I imagine the
bottom of the lake probably tasted like
I don't know if that was because it was
you know just a very old fish or because
they hadn't preserved it just right but
we ended up throwing it out
um which was kind of unfortunate but you
know a cool nonetheless that we'd gone
to all of that effort and trouble
so you know I continued fishing for a
very long time I haven't done it for for
quite a long time although I still do
have a rod and reel in storage and it's
mostly because of not finding the time I
tried getting my own children interested
in fishing and I succeeded a bit with my
oldest child but it didn't really stick
but my dad got the fishing bog stuck
with me
and you know he had
the intention eventually of taking me up
to Canada on the kind of trips that his
dad had taken him on we did manage to go
on a few longer trips up to Eagle River
for example I remember that was when I
was about 10 or so so like probably you
know later that year or the the next
year and unfortunately my dad died in
the summer of 1982 when he was only 36
and I was 11. so obviously we didn't
fish anymore after that but I I
continued um fishing you know by then we
had sold our boat to one of our
neighbors because you know without my
dad's income we were in pretty Dire
Straits and I continued fishing I would
hang out with you know neighbor kids or
some of my friends sometimes those
overlapped and we'd we'd go fishing
right and I did go on fishing trips with
other people and and uh my friends and
their dads and then when I was in
college I'd go fishing in nearby lakes
and down in the river as well and I
haven't really done much of it since
then other than when I lived in Indiana
and I would take my my youngest child
and we would go fishing but anyway
that's kind of a cool story of an almost
trophy catch an almost uh beating the
state record now you know the state
record's been beat subsequently so even
if I had one you know beaten one
achieved a new state record back then it
would have been surpassed by now but it
was uh it was a really interesting
um event in in my young life and I
thought I might share that with you and
you might get a kick out of that story
some of you probably have fishing Tales
of your own if you're going to share
them try to keep them you know as we say
more or less accurate don't turn them
into Fisherman's Yarns but if you want
to share them in your own comments below
that's perfectly fine so that is it for
this story